dna is perfect for storing and reading
genetic information
this information is stored in the
sequence of bases adenine thymine
guanine and cytosine also called ate
that I made that make up each strand of dna
each helix has a central chain
made of groups
the reading occurs in the  3
prime to 5 prime direction making use
of base pairing between
opposite strands of dna double helix in
these
pairings binds t and g binds ce
through complementary hydrogen bonds
base pair edges are
exposed at  the two grooves of the double
helix the wider major groove and the
narrower minor groove these edges are
also used to carry
information that is read by proteins that
interact with the double helix a good
example of the dna double helix is
code 1 bn  to which you can find
in the protein database
when you print the dna template you will notice
that it contains two types of models in
this model you can add your own
base pairs
this more detailed model shows all
the atoms in each nucleotide in this
tutorial we will use the smaller model
for demonstration however the
technique is the same for both models
first cut out the model
now fold all the lines
vertical solid gray lines so that each
vertical solid line is visible at the
top edge of the crease that was made
and then fold all the
gray vertical dashed lines so that
each vertical dashed line is
hidden inside the crease that was made
fold the paper along the  half so that the
central chain against it is first written
on the top sticks out
tuck the other fins of the
spine with 5 raw on
top one on top of the other now
temporarily fold the central chains so
that the model flat folds
the lines  horizontal and
diagonal
solid lines should be visible at
the top edge of each pl  Play with
dotted lines inside you can
unfold them and unfold them in any
order you like one by one
a good way to do this is to fold
all the horizontal lines then
flip the model and fold all the
diagonal lines the result should
look like a fan
the goal of the next step is to
make the various nucleotide base pairs
spiral on
top of each other
using the folds you just made
fold triangles that stack on
top of each other
your model should look like this when all
the lines  have been folded you
have the ends of the model to
open it and remove the central chains from
the sides
and as you can see the
finished model is a double helix dextro
rotates
you can use the tabs to connect
several models and make longer strands